[Music]
in lifting saves lives news submitted by
CUNY tyke Oh tacos gonna place the wrong
he is John yes yeah he's strong now
mm-hmm betcha kid he can't lift the card
Oh funny you mentioned that because wait
oh because of powerlifter heroically
lists a vehicle pinned on top of a man
after an accident did you ever hear
about the babies that live cars no when
they feel like mom's in danger ah babies
I've heard the other way around and the
moms in the carnival there's like
toddlers that have like super strength
and [ __ ]
like they're like Oh mom's drowning in
the [ __ ] pool and indeed all of a
sudden just Baywatch like a [ __ ]
and they go in there and they pull my
mom you know what you said people
there's like dad's [ __ ] getting
crushed by the car and then like baby
comes out and just lifts that [ __ ]
car up like that and then they get out
what if they do that thing that doesn't
even help where like the moms drowning
oh no they go lift up a car probably
more accurately mom's drowning they
reach down pick up a rock and just put
in their mouth yeah Thunder starts
[ __ ] coming on it
yeah so this took place in Michigan this
powerlifter named Ryan Ryan plates 29
years old filter yeah so he owns this
gym and so he was saying that he was
towards the end of his workday when he
heard this loud crash right outside he
noticed that there was a Jeep Cherokee
that was flipped upside down and so he
rushed to see if there was anything he
can do because he heard people saying
like Oh get the kid or something like
there were kids there but there weren't
any kids it was just this man who was
pinned under the Jeep Cherokee and so he
was saying that there were four men
they're all trying to move the vehicle
how'd it happen
but then he figured they're all [ __ ]
so like yeah my way he's like what a
better time than now to use what I know
I can actually do so he just jumped
right in he saw a window that was broken
off the back of the car and so he knew
that if he can swing the vehicle in a
certain direction he can free
dude from a poll because he was oh yeah
and oh damn yeah like a speed limit sign
how'd you get stuck in between a car and
the pole I know they don't say what
happened in the crash they just say
there was this crash probably someone
what David's look like they're just
walking and they're right wouldn't be
cross the pole in the park in him and
then if you crushed if you get uncrushed
does that mean you [ __ ] break in half
I mean you're probably pretty [ __ ] up
like you know like imagine if you're
crushed in between two things and then
when you win that pressure of that thing
like releases and it's kind of like now
you fall into two pieces
you know how far what are you gonna do
like leaving crushed together like or if
whatever crushes you leaves you in the
shape of what crushed you
that's why they'll be like if you get if
you get shot with an arrow you don't
pull that arrow Alex you'll bleed to
death you just break that arrow and
throw it out I've seen it in war movies
all the time it was the car with the you
know what's funny is that like you
mentioned signs but I didn't watch signs
I've only seen scary movie and I had
that whole like parody part where she's
like stuck in between it's about Oh a
Charlie Sheen and Denise Richards has a
funny scene you just stay in that
position
this is dangerous they say when you get
in a car accident you're not supposed to
pull people out they could get paralyzed
well he helped and so he was able to
move the car and the people there were
able to pull the man out and so he was
taken to the hospital he is the man that
was injured he's a father of five and so
strong sperm so Ryan was saying like man
I'm gonna father of two myself I can't
even imagine you know what if I wasn't
around for my kids whatever he was like
I just felt like I did what I had to do
because everyone's like you didn't have
to do it why did you do it because he's
strong it's not video of him moving this
club a video but I do have a photo of
him man I would have been there
supporting with my phone it's a big
person yeah that's right dog he's
warming up yeah you like get up get it
yes please
350 pounds yeah that way right there
he's just warming up he looks like a
kind of guy that goes to barbell yeah
yeah yeah so he's squat he has squatted
950 oh [ __ ] so he the man was pinned
behind this pole shot yeah that's
awesome
and then he lifted that car I wonder if
he like arm swiped the other three guys
like get away you old [ __ ] and he just
went like that or did they all do it
together
but in the the for wimps were like oh
come on we need your help
yeah we were trying and finally with his
help but what about the for wimps they
also need to be rewarded the for wimps
for without good hearts though yeah good
intention I like how you want them to be
rewarded while you call them wimps yeah
because they are isn't that that's
amazing I'd be like damn just [ __ ]
buff [ __ ] came in I wouldn't be
ashamed because he's 300 [ __ ] thought
I would be ashamed cuz I'm like man we
could have been the same but I didn't
work out so that's my you could never be
300 pounds during the 50 that's [ __ ]
give me he's like Bunyan dude you I've
seen five seven dudes that are 300
pounds they're sumo wrestlers she was
creepy she moved a two-ton SV that's
tight it had to be him it had to be him
in those guys oh yeah
no they were saying that like when he
was moving it that you could just hear
them say like all right all right let's
see now if we could get it we could get
him like telling him like we're good we
got him but he was just finishing the
workout yeah one more than one more rep
brah this swings it back
[Laughter]
I gotta finish the set he's about to go
one more step we have a report that the
man and another woman they were involved
in this crash and they suffered serious
injuries weird a woman no fatality
I don't know she probably was able to
get a home please through the window I
think it's dope because ever since I
started training and powerlifting I
don't take form or any of that for
granted for anything that I do now um so
just like picking up a box or moving a
couch or whatever like I I'm just
grateful that I know like the right form
to not ever hurt myself yeah yeah yeah
like when you grab that grocery bag you
[ __ ] go all oh you think you would
never be so whoa whoa that marshals
yesterday buying a couple of pieces of
furniture and stuff and like they have
the rule where you can't take the carts
outside of the thing like Oh ma'am do
you need help and I'm like no I think I
got it and then you just carry [ __ ] eh I
could do we yeah you utilize your body
and you're not a carry [ __ ] you're the
ladies man [ __ ] yeah like little things
like yeah that's so true cuz back when I
was weightlifting and I would be buying
a whole bunch of Kirkland water like the
what is it go cases cases thank you and
I would be listing I would be lifting
two of them to think and then going up
your stairs that's the old house
[ __ ] that I ain't even trying to lift
nothing I don't see the boxes and I'm
like woo I'm worried tired looking at
that [ __ ] somebody come do it yeah I
can't believe I did that I like working
out for fun
I said I like working out for fun not
for work when do you ever work out for
work no like if lifting boxes Oh gotcha
even though it's it's fitness like it
does you know get the heart rate going
and all that but I'm like oh [ __ ]
grocery bags somebody get it from a car
I don't want to do that consume we can
post makes it from your own car you
probably comes to train your dogs
times rabbinate I wish I'm always
talking [ __ ] to them to them like man I
feed your ass do everything you don't
[ __ ] do [ __ ] yeah they do they give
you [ __ ] IG video
kanta when you're there she's laying on
her stomach with her legs spread back
hey it is funny dude
the closer you get her leg goes like
it's like a Venus flytrap it opens up
and [ __ ] like because you get with
anything or with the camera no if you
get if you get closer to her like sure
she'll be chilling right and then you
start getting coasting should go [ __ ]
peppy she wants her belly rod i framed
Mattie the other day cuz Joe had the
dogs at the office and then uh you
framed yeah yeah sorry Joe is in the
bathroom and it's all my play with panic
like this like this and the Mattie
starts barking
I can hear from inside the bathroom like
Joey barking and then by the time Joe
came out I went into the bathroom and
then I can continue hearing Joe did you
see did you see the look on her face
when you told him that that you pranked
him we'll probably just like yeah that's
how you know you got him you gotta
really why did you picture I don't know
I just pictured I'm Maddie
this is Joe and behind him is Bart and
she's just like oh [ __ ] cuz she's like
you know it's like if I only in the
other speaking of it I miss Blair
thousand yeah she barks when she happy
she barks when she's sad she's barking
when she's angry she's barking when
she's work
she's always barking like she's always
communicating but if you cut her that's
not like a great idea
I would've never expected you to say
that because it's not true
have you done the spray thing what spray
you get the spray collar and it like
sprays or goes oh you know what burns
that it's you I'm liquid that that they
don't like yeah we've seen only know one
person that has it my dog used to be so
[ __ ] stupid that she would bark the
thing would spray and then she would
bark at the spray
she barked again just kept [ __ ]
barking it and take the thing off from
that yeah she was gonna drain the whole
cartridge out or whatever [ __ ] waste
of money that was geez they got the
electrical shock man that one in my
chick wooden hand I'm gonna set the pet
core Petsmart oh [ __ ] it is [ __ ] up I
mean they sell illegally that's my pet
pony why is it legal like whatever you
tested I guess it's not support it's
supposed to be a shock I mean I'm all
painful it is try it see if it hurt you
should I've done it yourself yeah yeah
but it's not like how it's like ah what
the [ __ ] it's like that oh so like
humane I don't know I don't know how the
dog feels I thought you know just for
yourself oh no wasn't torture for me
every Charlie Coshocton is it like that
you know with like the little pens it's
like it is like that so it's sort of
like a weirdo put it on your net so it's
weird cuz on your your neck is a weird
place to take pain cuz I didn't use or
did you just go to doggy school and
spend a lot of time and teaching them I
mean I know I could do it if I spend
more time to something like that yeah a
little doggy school what happened
tutor that came by we finished a lesson
she get better or like just it was more
about them coexisting as a pack and us
learning how to like kind of understand
the pecking order and then like building
the habits so it was just like basics in
everything so my buddy Richard has a lot
of military friends and one of them gave
him this trick that he taught his dog he
could get his dog to find anything in
the house so he would have him smell it
and then he would hide it and then he'd
say go get it and then he'd find it was
[ __ ] dope
[Music]